la 8e journée de la fraternité s'est
déroulée ce dimanche 25 septembre jardin
de l'état les représentants
interreligieux de la zone océan indien
se sont donné rendez vous pour une
journée de paix et de vivre ensemble
alors j'avais notre pays notre patrie la
france
le vit depuis fait
ces derniers mois depuis même l'année
dernière dans la dernière des moments
franchement terrible quoi avec ces
attentats c'est qu'on a constaté c'est
que
le cri qui a été
prononcez a précisé attentat est plus
que jamais la fraternité et nous à la
réunion nous dans nos usines mais nous
sommes héritiers
je méritais de la vivre ensemble et
extraordinaire qui sauve qui fait envie
à d'autres pays
eh bien je crois que nous avons le
devoir nous de consolider cet héritage
que nous avons nous survivre ensemble
fraternelle qu une journée de la
fraternité pour clôturer le 3e symposium
du réseau inter religieux de l'indien
océanie
en effet pendant plusieurs jours travaux
échanges et rencontres ont permis
d'établir des mesures pour la paix en
océan indien les grands axes de ce
symposium grognements on avait beaucoup
l'accent sur montbard m'en ont parlé des
ailerons parler de notre pays ont parlé
de cette entente entre heures dans
chaque composant de la société est
maintenant parle beaucoup sur l'indienne
et océanie nous sommes tous dans ce
bassin de l'océan indien et il faudra
presser davantage inculquer davantage
les valeurs qui nous unissent tous à nos
campus nous tous quand on rentre
donatelli vous partagez l'expérience
qu'on avait lieu sûr et pour continuer
ce travail pour développer cette entente
illicite entre religions peuvent être en
même temps une fosse de l'unité mais ça
peut aussi être une force des décennies
sur ne la connaissent pas bien on a on a
fait un état de la situation dans nos
pays qui d'une situation s'est
caractérisée par la misère qui par la
pauvreté et là quelle pauvreté fait le
lit de toutes les formes de violence
donc promouvoir la paix c'est d'abord
pour combattre la misère combattre la
pauvreté dans chaque pays
le département de la réunion qui à
travers ses actions de coopération dans
la zone océan indien participe à
perpétuer la solidarité et la fraternité
si chère au peuple réunionnais étaient
présents pour cette journée
ce département doit encore et toujours
plus vrai pour les valeurs républicaines
liberté égalité fraternité et laïcité
que l'on coud doit comprendre comme
cette possibilité de croire ou ne pas
croire ce si important là pour nous
parce que la religion
les religions joue le rôle mais aussi
les politiques et les bien drapés
effectivement nous devons tous être
ensemble pour pouvoir faire prospérer le
sicom de l'os indien une zone de paix et
de fraternité
et enfin dernière chose il est temps
pour notre là parce que y'a encore gérer
les réunionnais trop de doute trop
d'incertitudes trop de peur soyons forts
de notre tête de notre corps pour être
pleine marée noire être pleinement
français et poète paiement était aussi
une journée de convivialité de partage
d'idées entre les cultures pour faire
perdurer le vivre en paix dans les îles
de l'océan indien